the growing ecosystem of ibm cloud for
financial services
a free way to learn kubernetes with ibm
cloud labs
and policy-based governance in a trusted
container platform
all on this episode of ibm cloud now hey
everyone i'm ian and i'm excited to be
back to bring you the latest and
greatest news and announcements from ibm
cloud
last year in collaboration with bank of
america ibm designed an industry-first
platform called ibm cloud for financial
services that leverages the highest
levels of encryption certification
essentially it's the world's first
financial services ready public cloud
in addition to offering a secured cloud
platform we believe it is equally
important to build a trusted ecosystem
around it
that's why we're thrilled to announce
that more than 30 partners have joined
our ecosystem in the past three months
alone
together we're working to create a
secure financial services ecosystem
where banks
isp partners and sas providers can
define and monitor their security and
compliance obligations
and transact with confidence we also
provide a wide variety of co-creation
opportunities selling networks and
personalized go to market support for
our partners
if you're interested in learning more
about the opportunities and how your
company can join the ecosystem
see the link in the description below
next up i want to talk about ibm cloud
labs a really cool new set of
interactive kubernetes tutorials that
are completely free to use
ibm cloud labs offers hands-on
browser-based training for deploying and
operating
one free cluster on the ibm cloud
kubernetes service for three hours
no downloads or configuration required
all the tools you need are embedded
right in the terminal in the browser
in just three easy steps you can earn a
certification badge
just sign up for a free ibm cloud
account complete the tutorial coursework
through three interactive labs
and then put your knowledge to the test
by taking a quiz and that's it
a fantastic way to get some hands-on
experience with operating kubernetes on
ibm cloud
and who doesn't like a good
certification badge for their efforts to
learn more about this free opportunity
click on the link i've got below
finally to close out this episode i
wanted to touch on a partnership between
nist
ibm red hat and intel to build a trusted
container platform based on openshift
the platform ensures that workloads are
run on trustworthy nodes with integrity
established by a hardware root of trust
it also protects workload
confidentiality and keys which is really
important when dealing with regulated or
sensitive applications and data
this is the first demonstration of a
container platform with this level of
assurance and it's really interesting
and innovative stuff
if you check out the linked article
below you can learn more about the
building blocks and architecture for
this trusted container platform
thanks for joining me today for this
episode of ibm cloud now if you're
interested in learning more about the
topics i've covered make sure you
explore the links in the description of
this video
and of course please don't forget to
subscribe to our channel to stay up to
date on what's going on in the cloud
now